why do you don't understand why Trump
was so popular the reason he's left is
because people in Ohio have never seen
somebody like him he's what I calling
honest lion that first debate I've never
seen a white male billionaire screaming
at the top of his lungs this whole
system is ripped he said the cross stage
was white woman Hillary Clinton and
Barack Obama sitting over there looking
at him like no it's not I said now wait
a minute bro it's what he said and the
moderator said well Mr Trump did in fact
the system is rigged what would be your
evidence remember what he said bro he
said I know the system is rigged because
I use it I said damn and then Hillary
Clinton had a punch him in the taxes
said this man doesn't pay his taxes he
shot right back that makes me smart and
then he said if you want me to pay my
taxes then change the tax code but I
know you won't because your friends and
your donors enjoy the same tax breaks
that I do and with that my friends a
star was born Dave Chappelle's a
republican I'll take it it's fine